هذا هو هاتف سامسونج جلاكسي اس 4 الجديد
وهو افضل هواتف الشركه لهذا العام فهو
يحتوي على خصائص عديده قد تتوقعها من منتج
عالي التقنيه مثل هذا حجم الشاشه يبلغ خمس
بوصات مع شاشه عرض 108 بي ذاكره الوصول
العشوائي تبلغ 2 جيجا بايت مع كاميرا بدقه
13 ميجا بكسل وذاكره تخزين تتراوح ما بين
16 الى 64 جيجا بايت الهاتف مزود بنظام
تشغيل جيلي بين 4.2 وهو اخر اصدار من نظام
اندرويد وركزت سامسونج كثيرا على كاميرا
الهاتف اذ ان التقنيه الجديده تتيح لك مسح
الاشياء من الصوره اذا لم تكن ترغب
بوجودها في اللقطه كما ان هناك تقنيات
اخرى مثل تصوير الفاصل الزمني اضافه الى
امكانيه خلق صور متحركه بصيغه جف مع
امكانيه ايقاف كل ما في الصوره وتحريك ما
تريد
فقط الامر المثير في الهاتف ايضا هو حيل
التصفح حيث ان الهاتف يستطيع قراءه حركه
العين وتفاعل المستخدم مع الهاتف اذ تمكن
هذه الخاصيه من تحريك الصفحات من الاعلى
للاسفل اثناء نظرك الى الشاشه من خلال
اماله الجهاز الى الاعلى او الاسفل احدى
الخصائص الاخرى هي امكانيه توقف تشغيل
مقاطع الفيديو عندما تبتعد عينا المستخدم
عن الجهاز تلقائيا وعند نظر المستخدم مره
اخرى للجهاز فان الفيديو يعاود التشغيل
مجددا كما يمكن استخدام الهاتف كجهاز تحكم
من بعد اضافه الى خاصيه التحويم حيث يمكنك
وضع اصبعك قريبا من الشاشه للحصول على عرض
مبدئي وكانت هذه الخاصيه موجوده في اجهزه
نوت الا انه يمكنك الان فعل ذلك باستخدام
اصبعك
فقط كما ركزت الشركه على خاصيه الايماءات
اذ انك لا تحتاج الى مسك الجهاز لتقليب
الصفحه
فهذه الخاصيه تمكنك من فعل ذلك من خلال
تحريك اصابعك في المساحه الجانبيه
للجهاز